وثائق الرئيس الامريكي جوبايدن السريه
قضيه تتطور والانتقادات بتت نيران
الداخليه لاذعه مصدرها اعضاء في حزبه
الديمقراطيه فالاستياء متى يخيم على
افكارها عدد من الديمقراطيين تجاه القضيه
بمجملها بدءا من الاعلان عن اكتشاف
الوثائق مرورا طبعا للتصريحات الصادره من
البيت الابيض بشانها ووصولا الى العثور
على وثائقه جديده السنه تر الديمقراطيه
في مقابله مع شبكه تي ان ان قال ان على
بيض ان يشعر بالكثير من الندم على طريقه
التعاطي مع الوثائق السريه فيما اكد جون
روبن نائب مساعد وزير الخارجيه في اداره
الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما ان السبب هذه
الانتقادات الديمقراطيه هو من عدم انتهاء
الازمه في المقابل السنه هذه الديمقراطيه
وصديق بعدين المقارنه بالكريستونز حاول
الدفاع عنه بقوله انك اكتشاف اوراق جديده
في منزل بايظ في كابر يشتت انتباه
الامريكيين عن قضايا اهم بكثير وان قضيه
وثائقي السريه تختلف بشكل جذري عن وثائق
مرغو مرجعا السبب الى ان عمليه البحث عنها
جاءت بطلب من البيت الابيض على عكس
الوثائق التي احتفظ بها الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ورفض تسليمها
اذا قضيه هذه الوثائق جعلت الديمقراطيين
يراقبون تفاعلاتها بحذر والسبب الخوف من
ان تنعكس بداياتها على الحزب بشكل عام
وبيض بشكل خاص ففي كل مره يظن الحزب ان
الموضوع وصل الى نهايته تظهر اوراق جديده
الى العلم وتتاهب القيادات الديمقراطيه
مجددا لاحتواء الازمه لكن لا يجمع عليه
الديمقراطيين رغم هذه الانتقادات هو رفدهم
الواضح لاي مقارنه بين وثائق ايضا ووثائق
ترامب وفيما يامل الحزب الديمقراطي انت
تتلاشى الازمه قريبا كي يتمكن من الاعلان
الرسميه عن الترشحه للرئاسه اظهر استطلاقا
للرائي لشبكه اي بي سي يخالف امالهم حيث
اظهر ان 34% من الامريكيين فقط يظنون ان
تعامل مع الوثائق بشكل مناسب بعد نهايه
عهده كنائب رئيس مقابله 64% يرون انه تصرف
بشكل غير مسؤول